Income and wealth is not the opposite of poverty.
The opposite of poverty truly is dignity.
It's that ability to make choice.
Charity has a role, but it too often creates dependency.
Hey, everybody, welcome to the podcast.
My guest today is the very inspiring Jacqueline Novogratz,
who is this incredible woman who has made
an extraordinary impact on improving the lives
of millions of people across the developing world.
In addition to co-founding
Rwanda's first microfinance institution,
Jacqueline is also the founder and CEO
of this organization called Acumen,
which is a novel nonprofit that invests in people,
in companies and ideas,
solving the toughest issues of poverty.
She's a pioneer of impact investing in Acumen
and its investments have brought critical services
like healthcare, education, and clean energy to literally
hundreds of millions of low income people
throughout the world.
In addition to four TED talks under her belt,
Jacqueline is also the New York Times bestselling author
of "The Blue Sweater" and her most recent book
"Manifesto For a Moral Revolution",
which delves into the world's pressing need to reimagine
and rebuild systems.
So this is a conversation about many things.
It's about the humility, the patience, the immersion,
and the heart edged hope that's necessary for tackling
gigantic problems.
It's also about this idea of moral imagination
and the importance of transcending dualistic,
binary thinking and why that's required to,
not only eradicate poverty,
but also to solve all of our planet's biggest problems
and empower those most in need.
I so soon discover Jacqueline is just a badass.
She's very wise, but also deeply soulful.
I think we can all learn from her experience
and her example.
And I just love this one.
So here we are, please hit that subscribe button and enjoy.
So nice to meet you.
Thank you for coming out here.
It is so wonderful to be here, truly.
I'm a little nervous.
I'm intimidated by you.
No, you are not.
I am.
You're the ultra-
100%, 100%
that has millions and millions of people watching.
You're so accomplished.
And the level of impact that you've had
is staggering in such a beautiful way.
So I'm really touched and honored
to be able to spend time with you today,
to learn more about how you do what you do,
how you got there and really this beautiful struggle
that you talk about around committing yourself
to something bigger than yourself,
and what it means to live a purpose driven life
and pursue audacious goals with,
you know, humility and embracing the long path
and the obstacles that get thrown in your way
and to fear not, work that has no end, right.
I love that, fear not work
Which is this journey
that has no end.
that you're on.
Do you know Scott Harrison?
Of course.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
He says that a lot and I think about that a lot.
I love that actually.
Cause that's really,
that's the journey that you're on, right?
Like you're tackling such huge problems
that have massive scale and you're chipping away at it
and you're able to maintain this enthusiasm
and this positivity
and this level of immersion and engagement
that we're gonna talk about without losing hope or becoming,
you know, I'm sure there's discouragement,
but without kind of like losing that energy
that you infect all of these companies
and these people with, all across the world.
Well, thank you, you do the same thing.
Just in a different way.
I just feel like I sit here and talk into a microphone.
Sometimes I feel neutered.
Like, you know, when I read about you
and the more that I learn about you,
it's that boots on the ground,
like you're showing up, you got the notebook,
you're immersing yourself in these cultures
and really committed to understanding not just the problems,
but the people and what their needs are
and the best way to solve all of the problem
that of course includes capital, but above and beyond,
that really demands this nuance appreciation for
the very particulars of their problems
in the way that they lead their lives.
Well, thank you, but do you really feel neutered?
Because I feel that so much of leadership is finding
who you really are and I'm a doer, I have to build.
You amplify people, who they are.
I can already see what an incredible listener you are
and I've heard so many of your podcasts
in this moment where nobody's listening to each other.
And so we need those amplifiers.
We need the doers, we need the intellectuals,
we need the engineers.
And so I always thought if I didn't do this,
I could be a war journalist
but realize that I would be jumping into the war
to try to fix it like that.
Even though I a visual sensibility,
it's just not possible for me not to try
and build something.
And so do you really feel neutered?
Well, sometimes I just feel like I talk a lot,
but there's more that I could actually be doing,
like on that point of being a doer.
So I don't know,
Or we're defining
for you being a doer is
Maybe you can help me out.
Maybe you can plug me in somewhere.
Well, I totally could plug you in.
I know I'm scared, you know I'm really scared.
Don't ever offer me anything, Rich.
Oh, no, so many things I wanna cover with you,
but before we even get into like the whole story,
I know that you just returned from COP26.
So I'm really curious about what that experience was like.
And, you know, what you were kind of left with,
like how you're feeling about what went down,
the work to be done,
what might not have been addressed to the extent
that maybe we wish that it was being dealt with
in a meaningful way.
So yeah, like how was that?
Sure, well, maybe the metaphor, and I'm saying this
to one of the great athletes of the universe,
but it was grueling to be there, you know,
18 hour days, and walking really far,
and also exhilarating and also frustrating.
But the day after I threw my back for the first time
of my life, and I thought right there,
there's the metaphor that on the positive,
I actually think that the media covered it from the outside,
almost only looking through a negative lens,
a more cynical lens,
and certainly there is room for cynicism
and more importantly skepticism.
On the other side, inside the room,
governments were less vocal,
but civil society in the private sector
were really focused on getting things done.
I felt a shift in responsibility
that I've never felt in 20 years of running Acumen.
And that was very hopeful.
I went with two objectives
and two objectives only.
One was to ensure that the voice of the poor
was in every conversation.
Because we talk about the need to mitigate carbon.
And clearly we have to reduce it by 59 gigatons every year,
just to stay at 1.5 degrees.
But when we think about climate justice,
we often think about Europe and the United States,
people who are losing their jobs and we need to,
but so must we look at the bigger picture
that you're looking at a continent like Africa
where 45% of the population has zero access to electricity.
Where the median age is 19.7,
where if you don't have electricity,
you don't get to participate in this world
where most kids now have smartphones.
They understand what the opportunities are,
they're just locked out of them.
And so when we think about how we build a world
that is sustainable and inclusive and just,
we have to mitigate carbon, and at the same time,
we have to include people who've been fully left out
in ways that overt long term catastrophe.
And so it was frustrating that the poor were not included
in so many of the conversations.
And yet, I felt a great sense of efficacy in that,
that opened so many new conversations.
The second piece was to frankly,
find partners and raise money for the work that Acumen does.
Because I believe that we are on our way to electrifying
the whole world.
I don't wanna get too technical here on you
right up out of the box.
But because of the work we've done for 15 years
in trying to create solar light
and electricity for people who've been fully left out,
we've been able to get electricity to about
160 million of the world's truly poor people.
That represents one third of all people on the planet
who have access to solar light
and electricity off grid who are poor.
It's unbelievable.
It's been very cool.
It's given us a sightline then
to what it would actually take to achieve
Sustainable Development Goal 7 or universal electricity.
There are 800 million people still today,
150 years after Edison invented the light bulb,
with no access to electricity.
We think that the markets that have been built
will bring 450 million people into electricity,
a 100 million people will have to give systems too.
And then there are 230 million people.
If you give them access, they will pay,
they will want to buy their own systems,
but giving them access requires doing business,
not as usual and that's what we wanna do.
And so really felt a great deal of hope
that we were finding partners raising money for that effort
to bring electricity to everybody on the planet.
Well, It has to be easier now.
I mean, Acumen's been around for 20 years at this point.
And you know, you have legions of stories
around how difficult it was to get the financial sector
to wrap their head around this new business model
that you were proposing.
But after two decades,
there's proof in the pudding
and you're seeing so much positive result
from these many companies that you have seeded
and fostered that the model has established itself.
So it's gotta be easier, right, to get people on board
and see the vision that you have.
Easier still not easy enough,
you have a whole new generation that knows
that capitalism isn't broken.
And in fact, I would say, you hardly meet anybody anymore
that says unbridled capitalism is good for the world.
But getting from that statement to actually structuring
the right kind of capital at a level of scale
that will shift systems still isn't easy.
But it is easier because as you said,
we can now show that what's required from all of us
is to focus on this problems that we're solving first,
rather than the kind of capital that we have.
I have philanthropy so I wanna give it away.
I'm an investor so I wanna maximize my returns.
Well, money is money.
And so if we think about investment
as a means to solving a problem,
it changes everything.
And if we focus on building systems that start with,
what will it take to bring the poor in?
What will it take
to make sure that the environment is protected?
Well, then we can figure out the right kind of money
and the right kind of investment to get there.
There's so many things baked into what you just said
that I wanna, there's so many threads I wanna pull on.
I mean, the first of which is the kind of underlying theme
beneath all of it, is transcending this compulsion
that we have to think of problems
in the world in binary terms, capitalism,
socialism, for profit business, philanthropy.
And instead be, as you said, sort of problem-oriented,
like here's the problem, what's the best way to solve it?
Let's like get out of our, you know,
sort of calcified thinking around how we've tried
to solve these problems in the past unsuccessfully
and see if we can find a new way in,
that perhaps might be something we never thought of it.
Like that's the only way, right?
And then the second thing being this systems approach,
like you can't just show up,
here's the problem, solve it,
whether it's toilets or electricity or, you know,
affordable housing, like all of these problems
that you've tackled, the solution seems to always lie
in this immersion approach where you're boots on the ground
and you're really understanding what's happening
and creating infrastructure around those entities
that you're trying to create
so that they can function properly.
Like the toilet situation is a great example of that, right?
Like you can drop toilets in all of these places,
but if there's no one to clean them
or some kind of infrastructure to manage
the cleanliness of them, then they all fail, right.
So it's requiring you to think more broadly
and realize that it's not just the problem itself.
It's this concentric circle of problems.
Yeah, and you've said so much now
that I wanna unpack starting with the word transcend.
Because I do think that that's such an important word
for this moment in time
that we have seen the world in binaries,
rich poor, for-profit, nonprofit, even left right.
Maybe one of the most toxic in this country anyway.
That world may have worked
when we were fully separate from each other.
But in a world that's fully interdependent, it doesn't work.
We have to move to non-binary or non-dual thinking,
which I appreciate in the way that you think
and the way you speak.
And I love the story of the toilets as well,
because it's a long, hard grueling story
that also bends your mind,
because we look at these stories in partial ways, right?
We say so often when it comes to the poor,
we don't wanna give subsidies,
but we're not acknowledging, as the rich,
that much of our infrastructure is based on subsidies.
So if you look at toilets at the macro level,
one in three human beings on the planet
still have no access to a toilet,
which is mind boggling in and of itself.
The large majority of all subsidies for sanitation,
for the toilets we flush go to the top one sixth
of wealth owners in the world.
And that's because governments are willing
to pay for infrastructure.
If you're looking at a slum
like the slums outside of Nairobi,
where half the city lives,
there's no room for infrastructure.
You know, imagine all these little shacks
kind of tumbling over one another.
And these higgledy-piggledy little alleys going through them
where there's a lot of human waste
and other kinds of waste
because there's nowhere else for it to go.
And as you said, well-intended charities
and government programs would build latrines.
As soon as those latrines get filled, they're done.
The next progressive step there,
was government would hire people called frogmen
who would climb into the latrines and clean them out.
Not a great job but a paying job for people,
and so there were many people who did that job.
What this little company, and I say little at the beginning,
Synergy, saw was, one, the moral imperative
and also the adventure of solving
a big hairy goal like sanitation.
They went into the Mukuru slum in Nairobi,
three young entrepreneurs.
And they started by immersing, as you said,
this idea, get close to the problem,
understand it from the people who live their perspectives.
And they saw that not only do people
understand their problem,
but they wanted to be part of the solution.
That area outside of Nairobi or in Nairobi
is super entrepreneurial.
And that there were individuals
who were already creating toilets
that they were asking people to pay for to use,
but they had no resources themselves
to empty those toilets and keep them clean.
So Synergy built a system pretty much with a conceit
that I shared at the time.
This is a good 12, 13 years ago
that where government had failed,
the private sector could fix the problem,
social entrepreneurs.
And at the beginning it looked like it might work.
They would sell toilets to individuals who would charge
for people to use them, they would keep them clean.
There would be a mirror and a little vanity station.
Every day, they would pick up the waste
and they would put it into a composting area
with the idea that they would convert it into fertilizer
and somehow find a market for it.
But then you have other constraints.
Suddenly you have huge piles of fertilizer,
and it's really hard to build a market for fertilizer.
And you couldn't grow fast enough
because there was such demand for it.
That's when they started to recognize
that they actually needed to partner with government.
They needed different kinds of systems and standards.
And so they've since completely evolved as a model.
It's a hybrid, there's philanthropic components to it.
Now they're serving over 100,000 people in the slums.
I use those toilets whenever I'm there.
I can vouch for them being clean and safe
and a lovely experience.
But Synergy, it's creativity on creativity on creativity.
They realize it's really hard to sell fertilizer,
but what that fertilizer offers is compost
on which you can breed black soldier flies.
Those black soldier flies
then can be turned into animal feed,
which is a much higher protein than fish food, which is,
I mean, than fish, which is ground into food.
It also has much lower suffering associated with it
and much lower carbon because you're not moving from lakes,
fish to the lakes.
And so it's become one of the world's great examples
of a circular economy model
for how we can solve our problems.
Starting with people who have the problems
in the first place.
It's a model of partnership with government
and it's a model of getting serious
from a systems perspective of how we can solve
some of the great problems of our days
that are so complex and yet eminently solvable.
Yeah, that's a beautiful end-to-end solution
that I imagine they couldn't have envisioned
when they sought out at the beginning, right.
It was only in the doing that all of that stuff
gets revealed in the process of trying to make it work.
Well, you write about this in your book
that you don't start off and be like,
I'm gonna run five firebird, I just read it.
You start and you start to see
what the process reveals to you,
and that shows you where to take another step
and another step.
That's a big, you know, cornerstone, of your book,
this idea of when people come to you and say,
I wanna save the world
or your own experience of being younger
and imbuing yourself with that sensibility,
it can become paralyzing.
And the solution really is in the doing, right.
You have this thing, you just have to start,
like, what are you latching onto?
Like take that first step.
The way it's rigged,
you're not allowed to see where it's headed.
You only get to see the next step
when you take that initial one.
And the past slowly, you know,
the brick layer is like just one step ahead of you
laying the bricks down in front of you.
Our first COO, amazing guy named Dan Toole,
did not come from business as a background.
He worked in emergencies for the United Nations.
And he said, I feel like we're standing in
on the fifth floor of a brick building
and we're trying to build a terrace brick by brick
with no safety net underneath.
It's like, sounds about right, Dan.
Yeah, the story of your life.
It's the story, it's the story.
It's the sufi way.
I mean, which goes back also to transcendence
that there's this idea of how do you start a path?
You take a step.
Well, let's take it back
and kind of parse your path from the beginning.
I mean, you have a very interesting kind of origin story.
I mean, you grew up with six siblings,
seven of you guys, your dad was an army guy, a veteran,
and of all of your brothers and sisters,
they all seem to have like matriculated into the world
and they're all doing amazing things.
So like what was going on in that house growing up,
cause it's unbelievable between your brothers and sisters,
like everybody's doing something interesting it seems.
Well, we're all really lucky for sure.
The house was chaotic.
It was a small four bedroom house.
I mean we moved almost every year.
In fact, at one point we were in Mount Clemens, Michigan
during the riots.
But I think in part, because we moved every year
in the early years of my life until I was 10
and there were so many kids and so little space,
we had no choice, but to get along,
find ways to create play together.
My mother was and is one of the most extraordinary
myth makers and tribe builders.
And so I think she infected us
with that sense of both rules and possibilities.
And so if we would get mad at each other,
she would, one, let us know that she might,
you know, not like us in that moment,
but she would always love us,
but it was our job to show up for each other.
If we didn't like each other,
we had to love each other
and we definitely had to show up and we still do.
You know, my mother is still will give me the phone call,
like, what do you mean you're not gonna come
to your sister's whatever?
And I'm like, I just saw her two day years ago.
And you guys all live in New York?
We all live in New York.
Do your parents live in New York as well?
My parents live in DC.
My brother, Michael, who is in hedge funds
and then Bitcoin and crypto.
Yeah, he's a big crypto guy.
Big crypto guy, bought my mom and dad a house
in Long Island.
And so they're there about seven months of the year
and they're threatening to move from DC to New York
because they're in New York so much now.
But during the pandemic,
I think that was the big move where we were all together.
And in the summer, my parents have a barbecue at their house
at three o'clock every Sunday.
And it doesn't matter how fancy
your other engagement might be.
You better be at my parents' barbecue.
That's kinda how the Novogratzs normally rolls.
I mean, your mom just seems like a character,
like you're a Novogratz and this is the way we do it.
And here's what we're doing.
Especially since she wasn't the Novogratz, right?
Her dad died when she was a baby
and she grew up with a single mom in New York city.
And yet she built the myths and had high expectations.
And I think something you have said,
my mom said what, cause I was like,
you are creating all of these children
and we have no balance at this family.
And she was like, show me an ordinary,
show me a person who's balanced who isn't ordinary.
I mean, like oh God.
Yeah, it's a myth.
Talk about a myth, you know.
I love that.
Well, this, you know, it always,
you can look at someone's life
through the rear view mirror and it's like,
of course you're doing what you're doing.
Like it all makes sense.
All of these experiences that you've had
have added up to you being the person that you are
and the way that you kind of navigate the world.
But looking back, it appears that this, you know,
wanderlust and this sensitivity around poverty
and being a caretaker for those who have less,
has always been part and parcel of who you are.
Yeah, I think talk about lucky.
I think there are some people who don't figure out
who they are or what they want to do
at their most core part of who they are
till very late in life.
And I knew as a little girl
that I was going to do something both to serve,
and also as you said, to allow for a life of adventure
and that's really carried itself through
from the time I was six,
but when I was probably 44 or 45,
I got a random email from a boy I dated when I was 16.
And he said I was in the dentist
and I saw this magazine article.
And I just wanna tell you Jacqueline,
you're doing exactly today what you said you would be doing
when you were 16 years old.
And it really took my breath away
because I don't remember being that clear as a 16 year old.
I remember as a six year old wanting to save the world.
I was a normal teenager but I think I had that sense
that I wanted to make change.
And certainly there's inflection points
that end up pointing you in that direction,
but I can't help but think,
short of those stories that I want you to tell,
that somehow you would've found your way to be doing exactly
what you're doing anyway, right.
Like by hook or crook.
By hook or crook.
So you end up going to UVA,
you study like international relations and economics.
But the idea was you wanted to be a writer.
I mean, was the kind of, you know,
war journalist thing, part of that idea at that time?
Funny, I've never thought about that.
In a way I think at Virginia,
you know, my middle class army, military dad,
immigrant dad was the one when he found out
that I wanted to be an English major.
In his very quiet but powerful way said
that he thought that was a very bad idea.
How would I ever support myself?
And being a pleaser, certainly for him,
at that time I took on economics,
but I took every English course
that I could get my hands on.
And I think it was then, and I don't even know why,
where I would read certain camus, and even Joseph Conrad,
and find myself deeply drawn to this idea of good and evil
and how are there good people and bad people,
or do good and evil lurk within the spirits of every person,
which is what I deeply believe now.
And so maybe that was the connection then from early on,
a pull toward conflict and broken places
that started probably through my father being in Vietnam,
but then through literature.
So this desire to better understand the dynamics
that would create that kind of conflict.
Like are these people truly evil?
Who's good and who's the bad guy?
Or is there such a thing?
I think it was, is there such a thing?
Is there such a thing?
That early on trying to understand
the Contras and the Sandinistas
which was part of my generation's moral conundrum.
The deeper I would look into what was happening,
the less sure I was of who was all good and who was all bad.
And it was essentially recognizing
that I didn't have such a black and white
ability to come down with certainty that I thought
I probably wouldn't be a very good journalist.
But I wanted to know those places,
I wanted to be in those places,
I wanted to understand those places.
And then layered on top of that,
was this sensitivity around poverty,
that comes in part from stories your dad would tell
about being overseas being deployed
and the poverty that he bore witness to.
For sure, he's a quiet guy,
but I would ask him questions all the time.
And I was curious about the children mostly
and my dad worked with an orphanage
on one of his tours in Vietnam.
And it didn't make sense to me
that they were so poor and we were not.
I would say, it was also very much,
the Catholic school upbringing
and this social justice element of my family.
But honestly, Rich, it was also,
sometimes I think you're born with parts,
some of the seeds that become who you are,
that as a little kid,
I was always drawn to the runt of the puppy litter.
You know, my mother tells the story of,
you know, finally having enough money
that they could to buy this perfect english sheepdog.
I was probably nine and we went to the farm
to get the perfect English sheep dog
that she'd been studying.
And then I saw the runt of the litter
and was clearly had a problem
and probably blind and mentally disabled.
And I was like, how could you be such a horrible person
that you're gonna make us get this perfect dog
that every everybody will want,
we need to take care of the little one?
My mother was like, ohh.
You're just wired that way.
I think, I mean, I would ask you, do you think you're,
like who you are is probably how you came out?
A lot of it, you know, I believe in change as well.
But I think constitutionally,
yeah, we come out the way we are
and, you know, as a parent of four kids, I can tell you,
like-
which one?
They come out pretty quickly.
You can tell this is who this person is
and they stay that way fundamentally throughout their lives.
So, yeah, I think we come in with a certain wiring
and inclinations and dispositions.
And yet despite this, you end up, you know,
in this interview for Goldman Sachs
or not Goldman Sachs, Chase Manhattan, which is just like,
you know, confusing.
But I remember just to say,
like, I'm a couple years younger than you,
but I remember in college,
the career centers and the career paths
were not what they are today.
Like you would there and they'd be like,
well, it's Boston Consulting and it's Bain
and it's this investment bank and that investment bank.
And like that was kind of it.
And that was even more advanced than when I went.
You know, in our generation, in my generation,
there weren't a lot of options.
I didn't know what the nonprofit sector was.
I knew that there's charities,
but I didn't think there was an interesting career there.
I thought that if you work for them, you didn't get paid.
The only way to do it would be to volunteer.
And you were sort of Saint Lee, yeah, me too.
And I had paid for college.
I really wasn't that interested in going straight into work
after I had been working nonstop for my whole life.
I wanted to go, you know, ski in Colorado for a year
and experience what all my friends had had in their lives
that I'd never really been able to do, fun.
In that way, I always had fun.
And so our career office just had these little boxes
where you could put your resume into the different boxes
that took your majors.
And so I put my name in the boxes
and Chase Manhattan called
and I really said to my roommates.
I was living with these two women, I was like,
this is ridiculous, I don't wanna do this interview.
And they're like, just do it.
I promised my mom and dad that I would do the interviews
and I had one suit that I owned.
And so I walk into this interview
with my foreign affairs and economics degree.
And this really cute guy is sitting at a table
in this little room.
And he says, "So Ms Novogratz,
why do you wanna be a banker?"
And it was truly the one question
I was fully unprepared to answer, not being a liar.
I just didn't hesitate.
And I said, I don't wanna be a banker.
My mom and dad are making me do this interview.
And you could just see his face, just like,
huh, well, that's really unfortunate
because if you got this job,
you would be in 40 countries in the next three years,
learning all about the political and economic structures
and situations in those countries.
Which of course was a big part of really what I wanted to do
with my life, was to go-
I had never been outside the United States,
barely on a plane at that point.
And so then it was just like, man.
So I said, "Do you think we could
start this interview over?"
And he smiled and said, "Sure."
So got up, walked out of the room, knocked at the door,
extended my hand, said, you know,
hi, I'm Jacqueline Novogratz.
And he said, "So tell me, Miss Novogratz,
why do you wanna be a banker?"
And I said, ever since I was five years old,
all I've ever wanted to be was a banker.
And he laughed, I laughed.
And he is like, so, you know, let's see how good you are,
that he would throw out these questions that he'd be like,
so you're foreign affairs and your real focus
is Eastern Europe and Southeast Asia.
So tell me about the Middle East.
And I'd say, I don't know anything about the Middle East.
He's like, "I know, tell me about it anyway."
I was like, okay.
You're like, this is going very well.
I just assumed there is no way on earth
that this guy is gonna move me to the next level.
And I was a bartender.
I went to the bar, worked till three in the morning.
My little suit was crumpled into a ball
in the back of my backpack that I rode on my bike home.
Get home and pre-cell phones on the little table by the door
is a piece of paper that says,
"Chase called you back 7:00 AM interviewing."
I'm thinking, okay, how are we gonna pull this one off?
You're gonna have to iron that suit.
Got the iron, got the blow dryer.
I mean, Jacqueline, it's so crazy.
And I know you've been asked this before,
but there's a couple interesting things about this.
I mean, not the least of which is the audacity
or the gumption to tell the guy you don't want the job
right out of the gate.
That's very unusual.
Most people, you know, would be a shrinking flower
in the wake of such a question
and try to scramble to answer it in an appeasing way,
I suppose.
And then the second piece of asking for a do-over.
So there's this kind of truth telling compulsion
that you have and also this fearlessness
to kind of ask the question
that most of us would be too afraid to ask.
And on the point of you being asked this question before,
I still don't know that I've gotten a satisfactory answer.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
On where that comes from.
I do think inside of me and maybe everybody is this,
both the cocky and the unsure,
the audacious and the humble.
The worthy and the not sure how worthy you actually are.
And I do know that I am a truth teller
so much so that I'm really, I can't read speeches.
You know, I have to connect and just speak
and it drives my communications team insane.
And that's related to it somehow,
that if I know what I'm talking about,
I can talk about it,
but I can't make something up
unless everyone knows I'm making it up
and then I can have fun.
So I think the first part was, it was the truth
and I wasn't looking for a job and I was only doing it
because my mom and dad made me do it.
Not made me do it, but, you know.
And if you didn't want it, there wasn't much to lose.
The stakes weren't high.
It felt so ridiculous to me that I was in there
in this little gray suit that I got it hit or miss,
trying to maybe get this job, or maybe not,
I didn't even know.
And then the idea for me at that point
of traveling to 40 countries was like,
like not a possibility at some level.
And again, you know, I'm sure in my mind there was like,
I will travel the world.
Like Gertrude Bell on a camel, right.
You know, go off and be the lone wander,
not someone saying on a plate, I'm gonna hand this to,
you want it?
And there was no way I was gonna say no.
Yeah, it's exactly what you were hoping to manifest
in your life.
And you would then be getting paid to travel
all of these places and immerse yourself
in the economies of all of these foreign countries
and garner this unbelievable education
about how the world works.
And in truth, I had no idea what banking even was anyway.
All I saw was 40 countries where I cared about politics.
I cared about the economies.
I cared about people.
I didn't really know what it meant to be a banker.
And in fact, it was funny when I first came back to the bar
I worked at in the summertime
and everybody was so proud of me for being a bank teller,
which was sort of what everyone thought a banker was.
And truth was I made more money at the bar
than I did at the bank anyway.
So it was a funny moment.
The idea of investment banking and consulting,
I was still a few years away I think.
So you get the job, you move to New York,
and suddenly you're on a plane and you're flying around
and like, what are you actually doing
when you're going to these places?
So it was called credit audit
and we would be essentially handed this big stack of loans
that Hong Kong or Kuala Lumpur
or Buenos Aires offices had made.
And we would go on these big yellow sheets of paper.
We would look at the financials.
We'd look at the purpose of the loan.
We'd look at how it was structured.
Was it variable interest or long term interest?
And we would assess the credit worthiness
of the bank's loan portfolio.
The early '80s was a really powerful time to do that
because you had wild inflation and wild financial crisis.
So you actually had hyperinflation.
In one day, Brazil's currency could change by 800%,
always in the wrong way for Brazil.
So suddenly, company after company and nation after nation
was defaulting on their debt.
The same time, the Saudi gold,
I mean, oil was becoming like gold.
And so the banks were really liquid
or had been really liquid.
And so they were making stupider and stupider loans
because they had this money to push out the door.
And so from a macro perspective,
I found it just fascinating,
because for the first time in my life,
I saw the world as all connected.
That was happening in oil had a direct influence
on who was getting money
in another completely different part of the world.
I also saw how the rich were treated so differently
from the poor.
And that a hundred million dollar loans
would be made to elites in, I keep picking on Brazil,
but that was the country that had such an impact on me.
And it was clear if you,
once I learned to see story and narrative in financials,
it was clear that the person who borrowed
had no intention to ever repay.
Sometimes they would move the money right offshore
to protect it so that they had the money.
Sometimes they would use part of it.
But there was a lot of fraud
and the bankers often didn't follow up.
Everything was based on a handshaking relationship
based on being in the same club.
And so I found that both fascinating and terrifying,
and at the same time,
because we all read about the developing world
is these really poor places.
And yet there I was in this incredibly alive, beautiful,
colorful, joyous place.
I would be drawn into communities that were poor.
I didn't think of them as poor.
I just saw them as the most colorful, vibrant,
joyful, communities.
And then I realized those people were fully excluded.
They would never have a chance to get even a $10 loan
and maybe they would be better at repaying it,
because they would have such a sense of obligation
in ways that the too many, obviously not everyone,
but too many of the elites weren't taking seriously.
So walk me through the process of how you
take those experiences.
The more that you kind of understand the tectonic plates
of macroeconomics and how it's sort of marginalizing
and depriving these poor people of access to capital
and getting to understand
kind of what that dynamic looks like,
how you step into this idea of possibly tackling it,
you know, as a vocation.
You're a banker, I mean, you could have stayed there
and had this successful career.
You were moving up the ladder,
but at some point you jump off the chain.
You were talking about stakes in that first interview.
High stakes, low stakes.
I think it plays a big role in human beings lives
in those decision points.
Are you in a high stakes moment?
Are you in a low stakes moment?
And sometimes when it's a high stakes moment,
there's greater clarity to what the decision actually means.
So I would say two, if not three things,
were happening simultaneously.
One, I'd had this epiphany that the poor had no access.
And yet we were writing off
hundreds of millions of dollars of loans.
I didn't think I needed to leave the bank
because I actually loved so much about it
and some of my very best friends, I met in that period.
And I thought that my boss might be interested in the idea
of me building a unit inside of the bank
where we actually lent to low income people,
because I was sure we were gonna get better repayment rates
than the bank was getting at a macro level.
The second thing that happened,
I guess there were three things.
At the time, I stumbled across this article about
a little known man at the time named Muhammad Yunus,
who ended up being the founder of the Grameen Bank
and got the Nobel Peace Prize
for the work he did on just this idea.
He was the pioneer of microfinance.
He was one of the pioneer,
but he was the greatest storyteller.
And I would say there were three or four, but it was 1976.
Talk about patience,
when he first made 30 small loans
to 30 desperately poor Bangladeshi women
and saw that they all paid back
in a nation where the average were payment rates
at the banks were something like 15%, 85% write-offs, right.
So I read that, I was seeing it with my own eyes
and went to the bank.
And then the third thing that happened
was this incredible man, Tony Terracciano,
who was the number two person at Chase,
had offered me the chance to essentially
sit at his right side and build a fast track career.
And he was an extraordinary man.
I think he saw in me this scrappy person that he was and is
and so he kept raising the stakes, you know.
I wasn't fighting anything that was perfect.
I couldn't find anything in Brazil.
I knew I had stumbled upon this and I wanted to do it,
somehow test whether you could lend to low income people.
And so I was stumbling or fumbling
toward finding an opportunity.
Mr. Terracciano kept offering,
well, you wanna work in Spain?
Where do you wanna work?
Pick a place.
The Texas banks were hurting.
Go fix that, go help me fix that problem.
And I think that was the clarifying moment for me,
that here's a fast track, here's no track.
I don't know if you'll ever get on that fast track,
and my father definitely thought that I had thrown away,
you know, that once in a lifetime opportunity
and I might have, but I knew that if I went with him,
I would've stayed on that track.
That's a really hard track to get off of.
And there was no opportunity for you to say to him,
let's start a microfinance branch in Brazil
and see how it goes and let me run it
and prove to you that we can make it work?
Or was that something that was just too far afield
and not interesting to-
It's such a great question.
I might have lacked the courage or the imagination
because I asked my boss, who I didn't respect as much,
but maybe because this was like,
it was kind of,
remember that show get smart with the doors
that opened and shut?
Yeah, this is the big deal.
To get to the 60th floor,
You're in the executive
washroom going-
You took this big
all the way to the top and the doors would open
and he would be sitting behind this desk and I was there
with my, you know-
And you're 25, right, or something like that.
And I'm 25 years old.
Yeah, I think I may have lacked the courage
to do a deal with them.
It was either the deal's on the table,
or go off into this unknown territory.
So you split?
So I split.
Yeah, how were mom and dad with that?
Not great.
And again, you know, context in time,
I was going to a place they'd never been able to imagine.
Very few of us could.
No cell phones, no real way of connecting.
I didn't have health insurance.
I couldn't explain to anybody exactly what I was doing.
And ma'am, was it easy for them to tell people
that their daughter, and there weren't that many young women
who worked on Wall Street at the time,
had this fancy job where she was traveling
all around the world telling bankers
how to do their business better, that's a good story.
Telling them that they were living in,
I was living in places that they couldn't find out a map,
doing something that they didn't understand
or weren't able to articulate.
Didn't feel quite the same.
And then there was the fear factor,
I think, particularly for my mother.
My father had been in Vietnam.
For my mother, I was never gonna get married.
That was a big piece for her.
And something bad was surely going to happen to me.
And whatever come back.
I think we under-appreciate
the extent to which those social pressures
keep us in situations we don't wanna be in.
It takes a lot of courage when-
You're the oldest, right?
Mmm-hmm.
of all your siblings?
I'm sure your parents were very invested in your path
and all of that and it's hard.
Well, and also of maybe invested in me
continuing to be a role model and a helper
in the six that were coming up.
So, yeah, and you're a parent.
You wanna keep your children safe?
Sure, of course.
So how do you figure out what the next move is?
There was a woman at,
well, I wrote to the big names:
Muhammad Yunus, Abed, Ilabat in India.
Those were the days where it took 10 days
to get a letter across the world.
Nobody wrote me back,
but a woman I worked with had an aunt named Michaela Walsh
who worked with Women's World Banking
and she was in New York city.
And so I went to her and I said I wanted to go to Brazil
and I would help build Women's World Banking in Brazil.
And she said, that was great,
but they had no opportunities there.
And there was, however, a job in West Africa
in the Cote d'Ivoire.
Not exactly on my game plan, but I said, yes.
Didn't ask for any details.
Missed the health insurance piece.
And literally, probably a month later, sold everything.
My mother still reminds me,
you know, she had given me some good antiques
that were just left on the corner
first subway to pick up and-
Cote d'Ivoire
There I was, Cote d'Ivoire.
So I feel like this is another,
you know, this experience is another inflection point
in your education of appreciating the complexity
and nuance of the problems that you were,
you know, audacious enough to even tackle.
On so many levels, Rich.
Audaciousness but also arrogance.
It never dawned on me to ask
whether I would be properly introduced.
I was really happy with the way my job was described
that I would be an ambassador to African women,
and I would help them set up
these little microfinance entities across the continent,
starting in the Ivory Coast, the Cote d'Ivoire.
I had an office at the African Development Bank.
And it all just sounded amazing to me,
like this amazing entrepreneurial opportunity.
Of course, I get there and I'm fully and wholly rejected
by the West African women.
Wondering why a 25-year old who spoke terrible French
and had no understanding of their culture
should be the ambassador to African women.
Good point.
The white savior
here to save the world.
White savior.
Eye roles ensue.
And no one wants saving, thank you very much.
And certainly not by people who haven't even spent any time,
truly even understanding who you are, why you are.
And second, this was a very prestigious office.
And so there was also the other side
that why should I get it, not them?
And so I so ensued probably six months of failure
after failure.
Really, really difficult situations that were,
many of them from my own blind spots
and some from very ambitious women
who saw me in the way of their ambition.
And that was a very toxic combination.
So how long were you there?
I was only there for about six months but
it was definitely a defining moment.
One that almost broke me.
You know, they say, what doesn't kill you
makes you stronger.
Sometimes it just doesn't kill you.
I definitely remember walking down the street one day
where these dogs were growling at me
and just being like, go ahead.
You know, everyone else hates me too.
Oh, I know.
I was very low.
But it does make you stronger though,
because it's a formative experience in which you realize,
like you've been disabused of everything
that you kind of thought about how to approach these things.
So you depart with your tail between your legs,
but you've had a valuable experience.
I mean, you're very frank about these failures
that you've had along your path,
but each one of them kind of informs the next step
and all is part of this, you know, journey
towards really understanding how to be the best,
you know, steward and servant to these solutions.
Sure, it does make you stronger, there's no doubt.
It definitely, in a crazy way, reinforced my commitment.
I was not leaving.
And my parents lived in Germany.
My dad was still in the army then,
and I went to Heidelberg for Christmas time.
I was jaundiced.
I couldn't have been skinnier.
I was just this like tiny, tiny thing.
I was probably running 16 miles a day
just to probably run away, I don't know.
And then my mother and I had the big blowout.
Mom, I'd been-
Ooh, tell me about this.
Whether I had been deliberately poisoned
or I had mistakenly gotten the worst food poisoning
a person could get.
I lie in a bathroom floor for eight days,
really fully dehydrated and really in trouble.
I mean, just to be clear, when you left,
it was under a threat.
You know, there was-
There was threat.
Yeah, there was threats and you had been forewarned
that you could possibly be poisoned.
Yeah.
And you ultimately do get sick and it's unclear
whether you were actually poisoned
or suffered some kind of food poisoning or something.
It was definitely a crescendoing by the minute.
Yeah, but that's terrifying.
It was terrifying.
I mean, I left the country.
When I finally got well enough,
you know, I bought a ticket that day.
I did go to the women
in a way that does not sound like a broken person.
I remember looking at them, they were so beautiful.
And I was so conscious of being such a little bedraggled,
skinny, white thing.
And they were like these gorgeous women in these turbans
and jewelry and flowing robes of yellow and purple.
I mean, yellow and orange and pale blue.
I'm like there in the room with them.
And somehow I had the courage then to say,
I know I made a lot of mistakes,
but I wouldn't treat any creature the way you treated me
and I'm totally alone.
And we need to do better if we're going to heal this worlds.
That somehow those words came out
and I wasn't hectoring.
I was just, it makes me cry.
You know, I was just saying truths.
And they couldn't really take it in.
You know, it was just that then pregnant quiet.
And then I left, I left my two boxes of my prize poetry
and whatever random few possessions that I owned
in the hotel, never to go back and get it.
And so you can imagine my mother seeing this transformed,
young woman show up and announce,
well, now I'm going back to East Africa.
I still don't really have a job, but don't worry, mom,
it's gonna be fine.
You quickly recharged your battery and said,
I'm gonna go to Kenya, it was Kenya was next, right?
Kenya, Kenya.
Yeah, I don't even think I experienced my battery
as not charged at some level.
It was just, I'm gonna go,
I'm gonna be home, I am definitely gonna eat a lot.
My boyfriend met me in Germany
and everyone just was just like, you can't go back.
And I felt like there was a form almost of,
that their fear couldn't hold me back
and that if I didn't go,
it was going to affirm too many people's expectations
of what this place was, this continent was, that I knew
that even though these particular individuals and I
had had a hard experience,
I already had seen how extraordinary people were
and what was possible.
I knew I was in love with it.
And so, again, going from duality to the complexity
of what it means to be human.
I wasn't lying to that.
In fact, I was so drawn to life there
and to the people there and to the culture there.
But just as I could not go in any longer as a savior,
nor could I any longer see Africa in inverted quotes
as a perfect place where a community flourished
and everyone was kind to each other.
I went back after those two weeks as a,
a much more nuanced person going to invest, if you will.
Was a clear understanding that this was about
the human journey that I was a part of.
I was neither in control of it,
nor would I be controlled by it,
but that I wanted to engage in relationship.
And so to your point,
what doesn't kill you makes you stronger,
it was a rapid rinse and forget the dry cycle,
just throw you right back
but as a completely different person.
Right, with kind of this hope,
but a more harder edged hope and an appreciation
for the ferocity that is gonna be demanded of you
in order to just survive and make your way,
let alone, you know, produce change
or catalyze change.
And the beginning may be of a superpower
that I think that you have too
is being able to sit in a room and just really pay attention
to the room and to the people in the room,
not in a naive, idealistic, nor cynical way,
but start to figure out who's who in the room,
what dynamics are happening in the room?
I think that the experience in Cote d'Ivoire
really jump started it and then accelerated that skillset.
So that I could get really tangible things done
without losing that sense of idealism and hope.
And how long were you in Kenya?
Well, it's complicated because I was only in Kenya
a few months where I had another flaming fail,
that when these Rwandan women walked into my office there
and said, we are from Rwanda, I thought they said Uganda.
That's how I was at the time.
And they just passed a new law,
changing the Napoleonic code 1986,
so that women no longer had to get
their husband's permission when they opened a bank count.
And they wanted to see whether it might be possible to have
some kind of financial institution for women.
And it was the first time that African women
had ever asked me to do anything.
And so I said, yes.
Yeah, you're being invited,
which is a big difference.
Invited in.
Come in.
It was Fulikila,
was that her name?
Or was she later the-
She was a woman named Landrata who I changed her name
in "The Blue Sweater" and Rabokata,
who I changed both of their names
'cause I was worried when I wrote that book.
I went sort of similar.
I went with one suitcase, and then for the next two years,
I pretty much went back and forth between Rwanda and Kenya.
I would've stayed in Rwanda,
but early on a woman named Immaculae,
who was one of our co-founders
and one of the first three parliamentarians.
I got malaria and she gave me a big gift and said,
"We love working with you, this is great.
We're building this bank, but it is
you are maniacal.
You know, you're just going so fast
and our lives don't work that way.
And so if we're truly going to build this
as a Rwandan institution, which I was committed to do,
we've gotta do it in a way
that doesn't fully depend on you."
And I was both crushed and exhilarated
because I did want this to be a Rwandan institution.
I didn't wanna stay there for the rest of my life.
And so we came up with this plan
that I would work there for two months
and then I would go to Kenya and work there for two months.
And there was another woman who was a dear
and is a dear mentor from the Philippines, Mary Rosales.
She ran UNICEF regionally
and she saw that we were building a bank for women.
And Mary, who was the one I would really go to cry with
when things got really hard,
she said, "We have a lot of work to do with women
and enterprise and income generation.
And so don't worry about it.
We have a job for you when you're in Kenya."
And so I would flip back and forth between the two countries
for the next two years.
And this bank ends up taking root and becoming successful.
And what's interesting is that,
I mean, first, you know, I wanna spend some time
focusing on the fact that so much of the work that you do
and truly the solutions that you're committed to
are oriented around women.
And in particular with microfinance,
it's all about the women, right?
The women being the kind of financial bookkeepers
and the decision makers about how funds are allocated
and the empowerment of these women to create
some level of financial independence
and how that really creates a foundation
for a more functional society.
So talk a little bit about
like the women being like the key component in all of this.
So I never say this.
But when I first went to work with women in banking
and women in Africa, it felt a little funny to be honest,
because I was raised, again, a different generation
with four alpha male brothers
in a big patriarchal extended family.
And so I spent a lot of my youth
proving that I was as tough as the boys were.
And so this idea that now I'm going to do women's things
was not comfortable at the beginning.
And then I moved to Africa
and saw that 80% of the food was grown by the women.
Especially in West Africa,
you actually divided who earned income and what was paid for
by whom because you had these polygamous families.
And my whole world shifted.
When I saw, firsthand, how women were excluded,
how women, yet women were the backbone.
They were the backbone of family.
They were the backbone of who paid for school,
who made sure the kids got educated.
They were the backbone for culture.
And they did so much of the work
and yet were seen as chattel, as possessions, had no rights,
were not schooled.
And that fundamentally changed me.
And in some ways,
it is often the ones that are the doubting but curious
that I think become
maybe the best ambassadors,
because I never used the language when would see women
because I couldn't stand the language
of women in development.
Women are more honest, women are more this,
and I would think,
people are people.
However, what I did see was how women were systematically,
fundamentally excluded from opportunities
that would actually enable economy to flourish.
And that we will never build a world
when we systematically oppress and in some cases erase
50% of the population.
So that changed, again, a new layer of nuance,
that if there would be one man in the room at the time,
women wouldn't tell the truth.
And so I had to make rules.
If we were talking about Duterimbere,
which was the name of our bank,
the men weren't allowed.
Women needed to have that place
where they had the confidence
and the freedom to tell the truth.
Sorry to interrupt the flow.
We'll be right back with more awesome.
But first I do wanna snag a quick moment
to talk about something I care a lot about,
which is the importance of nutrition.
And the thing is,
most people I know actually aspire to eat better,
to incorporate more whole plants, fruits, vegetables, seeds,
beans and legumes into their daily regimen.
Sadly, however, without the proper tools and support,
very few end up sticking with it.
And so because adopting a plant-based diet
transformed my life so profoundly,
and because I want everyone to experience
some version of what I've experienced,
we decided to tackle and solve this very common problem.
And the solution we've devised, I'm proud to say,
is the Plantpower Meal Planner,
our affordable, all-in-one digital platform
that sets you up for nutrition excellence
by providing access to thousands of customizable,
super delicious, easy-to-prepare plant-based recipes.
Everything integrates with automatic grocery delivery.
You get access to our team of amazing nutrition coaches
seven days a week, and many, many other amazing features.
To kickstart your health intentions this new year,
we're offering you $20 off,
a one-year membership with a code POWER20
throughout the entire month of January.
Again, that's promo code POWER20 for $20 off
at meals.richroll.com.
All right, back to the pod.
There was this idea, you know,
in the early days of microfinance
that it would just be throwing money away,
that these people would not repay their loans.
And in fact, it's quite the opposite.
Like the repayment percentage is way higher than it is
for loans doled out to, you know, higher-
People like us.
Socio-economic echelons.
But that was also a lesson that you learned, right?
Because initially there were some issues around that
until you built in the accountability piece
that has the added bonus effect of also kind of
sewing the seeds of dignity,
which is like a huge part of this whole mission.
Yeah.
Rwanda was a big age recipient.
And so the way people interacted with
particularly anything foreign was to accept grants.
You'd walk down the street and kids would say,
(speaks in foreign language)
Give me 10 franks.
And I would say, no, no, no, no, no.
I'd be like,
(speaks in foreign language)
10 franks.
No, you give it to me.
And they would look at me like, but you're rich madam.
And I'd say, let's talk, let's have a conversation.
It so offended me that we had these so many people
who were interacting in a way that was tantamount to begging
and not enabling themselves to be who they could be.
So when we first started,
particularly this bakery that I started,
the women ripped us off blindly.
It didn't take much.
Because it was
government run, right?
It was like this charitable organization.
So nobody was invested.
It was run
by the good sisters.
It was a charitable organization, not government,
but they
probably wisely took what they could take
when it was clear.
And they finally believed me that this wasn't mine,
this was theirs.
And so we had a choice.
We build it in a way that is financially sustainable
and then allows them to grow and prosper.
Or it becomes like too many of the other stupid projects
that we had seen where it works for a few years
and then it's gone.
How does that happen?
There are so many well-intentioned people in philanthropy,
and yet, you know, there's just too many stories
of, you know, funds just ending up-
You know, there's all kinds of
issues around corruption
and just organizations being poorly run.
And the money seems to disappear
and nobody ends up benefiting and it's all like
just a big cluster folk.
Like how does that happen with people who I'm sure
are trying to do the right thing and help?
I often say that distance dulls the moral imagination.
And so we wanna do good.
We wanna be part of good.
And so we give money hoping it does good,
but that's not enough.
We've actually got to build in systems that have like,
to your word, of accountability,
generosity without accountability
can really make a mess of things.
And it's not the same as justice.
Justice is hard.
Generosity can be hard, but it's a lot easier than justice.
And so when there's no accountability and systems,
and if you think about an aid system
where people are coming and going,
they're not vested, it becomes even easy.
Or for many of the different flares to take different pieces
of whatever is available.
So it's gotten a lot better,
but I did this study of 200 of these women's groups
in Kenya in one of the two months that I was there.
And what I saw was a pretty terrifying cycle
where the philanthropist or the aid organization
would give money to a women's group.
They immediately would give a 10% kickback
to the local district officer
because the money had to go through him.
Then they had no skills
to cooperatively run their chicken farm
or whatever they were given the money for,
usually decided by some government official or a foreigner.
The whole thing would fail.
But whenever the dignitaries would come
to see how the project was doing,
the women would parade out some little chicks,
they'd put a show on, they would go by Fantas and biscuits.
Sometimes they would kill a goat.
And after looking at these 200 groups,
I could only conclude that the majority of them
were spending money to keep this whole farce alive.
And I remember staying up all night, one night,
writing the report and the first line was,
good intentions lead the path to hell,
another famous saying of my mother.
And I just felt such rage that there was a machine
that ultimately was a big lie
that if we really cared about enabling people
to solve problems,
this is not the machine we would be doing.
And on top of that,
you know, as generous as the spirit is that's donating
all of these things, it doesn't respect the dignity piece
because nobody wants to be just a charity case, right?
Like this is another kind of facet of the things
that you talk about out in the book,
which is finding a way to inspire that dignity,
and that comes with this model and this approach
where these people aren't on the receiving end of charity,
they become stakeholders and invested.
So you're aligning the incentives, right?
A lot of these problems you're talking about,
there's a misalignment of incentives
that butts up against a lack of accountability
that creates like all of these problems.
And Acumen is really a re-imagination of the model
that is this hybrid between philanthropy
and, you know, proper investment banking or venture capital
to get those incentives in parallel with the best interest
of solving the problem
and getting people really engaged themselves,
the people who are on the receiving end of it.
Is that fair?
(indistinct)
I don't know, I don't feel like I articulated
that very well at all.
It was beautiful.
You articulated it beautifully because yeah,
what I learned more than anything else
and certainly after the one in genocide,
but in story after story like this is that
many well-intended people see a chance to give a grant
and get people a little bit more income
for their income-generating project.
But that income and wealth is not the opposite of poverty,
that the opposite of poverty truly is dignity.
It's that ability to make choice.
And so when I started Acumen,
the whole focus was on what systems would you build
to enable human dignity
rather than just make sure people get some income.
And it felt very clear to me then,
particularly after all of these experiences,
that markets have a real role to play
because there's a distribution and a scaling that's natural.
You have self-organizing mechanisms
through the good part of capitalism
and it's limited.
It too often leaves out the poor and in the worst of cases,
it exploits the poor.
Charity has a role, but it too often creates dependency.
So what if we took philanthropy and invested it
in those entrepreneurs that were hell-bent
on solving some of the biggest problems of our day,
like sanitation, like education, like energy,
like agriculture?
What if we gave them time to really understand
the true constraints and the obstacles
that get in poor people's way and build solutions
so that at the end of the day,
they could send their children to schools
they wanted to send their children to,
they could get access to good healthcare,
they could get electricity.
Although I wasn't thinking about electricity 20 years ago.
And because what I'd seen over and over
was that the poor actually pay more in these broken markets
than the middle class pay anyway.
It's not like the poor is sitting around
waiting for somebody to get them water.
It just happens to be dirty.
And the water they get access to is often supplied by,
what's called mafias, extortionary providers.
And so it seemed to me that we could start with recognizing
that every human being wants to solve their own problems.
We wanna be part of contributing in one way or another,
and build those systems that, at the end of the day,
not only allow that kind of flourishing,
but solve all of our problems.
Well, first of all,
I think you should run your own marketing department
at your company because that was beautifully put.
Thank you.
And secondly, you know, this begs the question
of two things, first, this idea of patient capital,
because these, you know, if you're gonna change systems
and, you know, address infrastructure
and create these proper incentives and all of this,
like this is a lot of work
and this is gonna take a lot of time, complex, right.
And then second to that,
but very important of course,
is redefining how you think about success,
not in terms of profit and loss or investor return,
but more broadly in terms of,
I feel like the word impact gets thrown around a lot,
but like you tell me like what the metrics are
that you came up with in order to gauge whether,
you know, an infusion of capital or, you know,
lifting up entrepreneurs who are gonna go into these areas
and solve a particular problem,
like how you're you gauging their progress
and, you know, whether they're successful or not.
There are a lot of questions in that.
I know I was sorry,
that was more like a grunt.
No, that's good.
It's good, it's good, it's good.
I think I know exact,
I think I know where you're going-
I'm not very good at asking questions.
I just throw stuff out there.
You're awesome at asking questions.
And like I said, the honor of being listened to is just,
you're amazing, thank you.
Entrepreneurs that are building markets
that have never existed, don't know how to price.
They don't have a distribution center, system.
You know, you think about it, let's look at electricity,
which is one I've told before, but in 2006,
1.5 billion people on the planet
had no access to electricity.
Two young guys, Sam Goldman and Ned Tozun,
come forth with a solar lamp
which makes sense to people like us.
We've seen solar before.
What they didn't fully get
was that their customers would make two or $3 a day.
They would exist in places
that had very little infrastructure,
no distribution channels,
low income people
had no way to finance these solar lanterns.
And equally, if not more importantly,
they had very little trust of this new fangled technology
that may or may not work.
$30 was the first price point.
And that's a lot of money
for people who make two or $3 a day.
And so our idea was we would take this philanthropy.
We would invest,
I thought eight years would be long.
We're still in 14 years later.
And that we would accompany this, the company as well.
By that, I mean we would use our social capital,
our networks, our access to corporations,
we would help them raise grant money
so that they could build marketing systems
so that they could experiment, so that they could fail.
And any money that came back to Acumen
would be reinvested in other innovation
serving low income people.
That single company, d.light, has now brought
affordable light and electricity
to over a hundred million people.
We then continued to learn with them
and realized that we had to build a market.
And so we then started investing in other companies
like d.light as well as financing companies
and in mini grids and what was called nano grids,
like just a few houses hooked together.
And you asked, how did we know if we're making a difference?
How do you measure impact?
Well, we knew we could tell you how many people
were getting access to light.
We didn't know if it was changing their lives.
We knew how much carbon we were displacing
because prior to the solar, they were using kerosene, right,
which is dirty and dangerous and terrible for your health.
But we developed something called lean data,
which is a way of texting 5, 10,000 customers simultaneously
asking them a series of questions
from which we could deduce,
how many more hours were you staying up at night?
What do you do with that time?
Do your children do better or worse at school?
What do you like about this?
Would you recommend it to your neighbors?
Et cetera, et cetera, et cetera.
So today we're the largest off-grid
energy investor in the world.
One third of people on the planet
who have access to off-grid solar and light and electricity,
our customers of the companies in which we've invested.
We have a very good idea of which companies
are most effective at reaching the poor people,
reaching low income people.
Which companies
have the most effective light luminocity?
So the bright light.
Which are best for displacing carbon?
Which companies provide the greatest customer satisfaction?
And so we can now make decisions
for how we allocate our capital based,
not just on financial performance,
but from all these other indicators.
Yeah, it's beautiful.
I mean, those are things that are never gonna show up
on a spreadsheet, like how many young people
stayed up an extra hour to study,
and how do you gauge the long term impact
of something like that purely
because somebody has a light that they didn't have before.
And Rich, you talk about dignity.
If you wanna see dignity manifest,
go into someone's house who has forever,
for every generation,
just seen darkness descend at six o'clock
if you live near the equator
and watch them flick a switch and light up their home.
We so take that for granted.
We so don't think about what it would feel like
in an isolated or very congested slum area.
The fear at night, the sound of the bugs of human beings,
all that changes.
And what's shocked to me
when we first started to see these units being sold
was that often the first light that the woman would place,
would actually go outside the door
and be their security light.
And so how do you measure that?
I feel safe.
I mean, that would be
something you probably wouldn't have thought of, right.
Never thought of it.
I wanna better understand this idea.
You said, a minute ago,
we knew that if we want to address this problem
of just electrifying homes and getting lights in them,
that we had to create a market, right.
Tell me what that means.
Like the way I think about that,
and tell me if this is wrong, of course, there's that adage,
like don't give a fish,
you know, teach somebody how to fish, but this is like,
we're gonna create a whole fishing infrastructure.
We're gonna make the poles and we're gonna,
you know, dam the river and we're gonna-
That's exactly what this is like.
You have to like create all of these other things
in order for that one thing that you're focused on
to even take root and function properly.
Absolutely, and I don't think I understood
at the beginning that we were helping to build a market.
And obviously we were one player of many,
but I used to say when people would say,
oh, so what Acumen does is teach a man to fish?
And I would say, with all respect,
if we're working in a coastal community,
they know how to fish.
Right there, yeah.
They tell you how fishing works, right?
They don't need us to teach them about fish.
They need a cold chain.
They need to know that when they fish in climate crisis
and it is so hot and they're bringing back
their lower stocks of fish,
because our oceans have been depleted
and they can't keep them cool,
they're gonna lose all their fish.
And so unless we find them ways to get them a cold chain,
it does matter if they know how to fish.
We need to find them people who will buy the fish
at prices they could afford with some level of transparency.
And I would just go off.
So what I was essentially saying,
without understanding what I was saying,
we gotta build a market, that is what's needed.
And after 20 years of investing patient capital
and we've invested about 140 million
in about 135 companies on the patient capital side.
And then we have about 200 million
that we manage for profit funds,
but on the patient capital side.
Building new markets is one of the most important things
that patient capital is used for
because you're essentially going to places
where functioning markets have never existed.
People depended on kerosene.
Kerosene is, or diesel in Nigeria.
Everyone knows how that market works
and it's highly extortionary, very subsidized by government.
You get votes if you get people kerosene.
So now we're gonna create a new market
that gives more ownership and power to individuals
by disrupting the one that already existed,
that is really hard to do.
In the United States,
you would get billions of dollar or millions, at least,
from government.
Look at Tesla, but when it comes to poor people,
that money doesn't exist.
And so patient capital is in a way,
a form of that early stage R&D marketing,
finding the entrepreneurs,
supporting them to build different parts
of what I would call the ecosystem
so that you are enabling different companies then
to service a whole industry that had never existed.
And then the piece that we don't talk enough about
is that if you do that well,
and you solve a fundamental problem,
like the lack of electricity, so do you create jobs.
And so we are, we may be the biggest investor,
but there are many investors now
in the off grid solar industry.
That industry has gotten 400 million people
total access to electricity
and created 400,000 really good jobs, like careers.
And that's how we need to think as a world,
including in the United States.
If we solve our fundamental problems
in ways that transcend left thinking, right thinking,
it's the government, it's the private sector,
but actually use the tools at our disposal,
we could build a better country,
include people who've been, for too long, left out,
get rid of some of the left right conversation
that only reinforces inaction,
and most importantly solve some of our biggest problems.
Right, this idea of moral imagination.
Moral imagination.
Yeah.
It requires you to step outside of that rubric altogether
and just see all of this and appreciate it
in a broader context.
So yeah, talk a little bit more about like what that means.
Yeah, and I would say, even since I wrote
"Manifesto For Moral Revolution",
my understanding has deepened
because I think it also starts with seeing
the moral force in other human beings
and all other human beings.
And it's this idea that we can solve our toughest problems.
We start with a sense of empathy.
I see you, first and foremost.
I understand that you have a problem,
but if you just stop at empathy,
you've reinforced the status quo, oh my goodness,
I feel so sorry for you.
This is a terrible situation, period, so what?
The next piece is immersion.
We talked about it with Synergy, the sanitation company.
Get close to the problem, understand it.
Understand it, not from your perspective,
but from the person who is actually
dealing with the problem.
And the third is then to analyze it systemically.
What are the forces that get in that person's way?
And can you be honest
about where that person might get in her own way?
And then finally it goes to action.
For short term is willingness to see the world as it is.
And that takes a lot of humility and truth,
yet always holding to the audacity of the world
that you're building.
Those d.light guys, from the very beginning
they were in their 20s, were going to light the world.
They were going to eradicate kerosene.
It was crazy, an impossible idea.
And yet they had to deal with the junk around them
of status quo, including the diesel mafias
that didn't want them to succeed.
The poor who didn't trust them.
The lack of financing, inertia, complacency, bureaucracy,
they had to fight all of that and not turn away from it
with just silly idealism,
not just buy the stuff and hand it out.
We call it spray and pray.
They had to build a system.
They had to build a company.
They had to build a market.
That's the hard work.
Like making the light is the easy part,
is the easiest part in the whole thing.
Oh my goodness.
And this gets played out.
I mean, threat you have a million examples of this
in all of these companies that you've worked with.
I mean, the intraocular lens company and the mosquito nets
and the coffee company,
like that's a whole fascinating thing about
kind of, you know, dealing with the commodities market
and affordable housing.
And, you know, the list goes on and on and on.
Yeah, so many engineers over the 20 years have come to us
and said, Jacqueline, this is the best water technology
that the world has ever seen.
It will solve all the problems of poverty.
And I'll say, well, go try it.
And they'll say, no, no, I built the technology,
you go build the market.
It's like technology is the easy part, my love.
Have you spent time with people to actually understand
how they make decisions, what they value,
how much money they have, are they willing to pay?
'Cause I promise you this, you wanna get people water,
you gotta deal with the fact that
many of them think water comes from God.
God will decide whether they get sick or not.
It doesn't matter if you think it's so clean.
We had this company that did reverse osmosis.
No, they did desalination
to get all the impurities out of the water.
They made the water too pure
and people didn't like the taste.
So you've gotta have-
It's all about taste.
Is this something people will value?
Can I get it to them in a way that they can afford?
'Cause if I can't, you're gonna fail.
Right, and that whole message
is like a fly in the ointment of Sandhill road, right?
'Cause it's all about the do dad.
Like if you just make the best do dad,
we can change the world.
And there is an arrogance built into that
and a lack of appreciation-
And move first impressions.
Right, right, right.
And what we're seeing in the world is move fast
and break things can sometimes really break a lot of things.
And so when you're dealing with very vulnerable societies,
communities that have seen
cheats and charities come and go,
they have good reason not to trust.
You can't move fast and break things.
You have to make a commitment to show up and show up
and show up
and take the problems on with the people
that you are there to serve.
And that's what separates.
I bet you talk about this in your book.
It's that persistence thing.
You don't have to be the fastest, but you have to,
what do you say?
The prize goes to the person who slows down the least.
You gotta just keep the slog.
Yeah, it's not very romantic.
It's not very sexy.
'Cause that's the heavy lifting
that you do behind the scenes when no one's looking.
It's not very sexy.
But when you go into a village
and everyone has light and electricity
because of the companies that you have-
Oh, it has to be unbelievable.
It is unbelievable.
I was sitting with a Rajasthani woman, a group of them,
and we were talking about their d.lights
and I was complimenting them on the courage
to move from kerosene to solar
and asking them for the different reasons they did it.
And I was hearing all the same reasons
that people talk about.
You know, they could go to the bathroom at night
and see snakes with their light and saw security again.
But the children studying, et cetera, et cetera.
And then one woman said, "I don't feel stressed anymore."
And I said, what do you mean you don't feel stressed?
And she said, "Well, when I had a kerosene lantern,
I was always worried that it might fall over
and hurt the children or even kill them."
And I said, well, that's very interesting, ma'am,
because, one of the founders, Sam, started this company
because he was living in Benin, West Africa,
and his neighbor's kerosene lantern fell over
and burned down the house and nearly killed
his eldest child, so he started d.light
and now I'm sitting across from you.
And she looked at me and tears came down her face
and she said, "Please madam,
would you thank that young man for me?"
And I thought,
what is success?
Making all this money?
Or being Sam Goldman?
And having a woman
on the other side of the world illiterate.
I don't know how she make my dollar, $2 a day,
thanking you-
It's pretty cool.
for changing her life.
Yeah, it's so cool.
What an amazing life you've lived!
I mean, the legacy of that and the impact
and hundreds of millions of people impacted
by the work that you're doing and being kind of like,
you know, an iconoclast in your earlier days
and now sort of a mentor to so many young people
and to kind of bring it back around to COP26.
You know, my only take away from that
is what I read in the press.
That's why I asked you, like, what was it like being there
and what did you take away from that?
But my sense is that,
with our generation, there's a calcification around,
you know, we'll do just enough.
You know, we'll do just enough, we'll say the right things.
We'll make some slight adjustments,
but there is a lack of appreciation
for just how dire things are and the radical shifts
that need to be made
in order to truly address this in a meaningful way.
And then we have a whole younger generation of people
coming up who are incredibly passionate about this,
who mean business,
who can look to you as this light house
who has, you know, guided their path in certain ways
and the level of enthusiasm like this.
The things that you care about
seem to be the point I'm trying to get at in elegantly
is that your sensibility seems to be part and parcel,
like built into the DNA of the generation
that is coming up right now, which gives me hope.
And so I suspect that you have quite a few opportunities
where you're talking to young people
and gauging their interest level
and trying to guide them into, you know, the right pathways
for them to express their talents
in the most meaningful way.
Well, thank you for saying that.
I feel that I sometimes am clunkier than I would like.
I loved your podcast with Adam Grant
where you said that you were neither a politician
nor a preacher but lighthouse.
And when you said it, I was thinking,
I think that's the category I would be in as well.
So I also, just,
it's interesting that you put it that way.
We're creating our own category.
Adam Grant, he's gonna have to write another book.
He has to write another book.
He has to figure out a piece.
He forgot about the lighthouse.
He forgot the lighthouse.
Adam, aging Adam Grant.
Well, the lighthouse though
is sometimes complex with this next gen, in that,
'cause I agree with you, the next generation understands
we need a new capitalism and the next generation is,
well, what is the next generation, is complex.
I think that generations are almost new every five years.
The youngest one that's coming up, I think,
really is focused on building.
And building is less pure than the ones that just tell you
everything that's wrong with the system.
And I think there's an important differentiation there.
One young woman read my book,
"Manifesto for Moral Revolution," and said,
"I thought I was gonna read Angela Davis."
And here's a woman who's talking to me about markets.
I hate it, and I was like, good point there.
It's a very bold title.
I mean, if you're gonna write a book and you're gonna,
first of all, the first word is manifesto,
it's like, how dare you?
Oh no, no, I know, I know.
No, no, don't go there.
And then a moral revolution?
I might have jetted a little bit different.
Yes, Jacqueline being the arbiter of all things moral.
Oh, oh, I just got this great,
one of our Dutch entrepreneurs who can count on a Dutchman
for just telling you like it is.
He said, I didn't wanna read it
because I thought you were gonna do all this moralizing
and then I read it.
And all I saw was myself,
that it's really all about all of your struggles.
And I so related to that part of it.
But what we were talking about was really this next gen
and what they relate to is a world that is inclusive,
that is just, that is sustainable.
That we have to build a new set of tools.
There's a big debate around,
are you tweaking the edges
by continuing to even use capitalism
or the tools of capitalism?
Or should we destroy the whole thing?
It's back to the nuance thing and the non-binary.
And that's where I will always make that plea for nuance
and try quickly to go to those examples
where we have a radical generation of entrepreneurs
that are coming up and what gives me energy, Rich,
is not my ideas but really learning from their ideas.
In some ways they are mentoring me
and allowing me to be an iconoclast again,
which is so exciting, because I would say,
the last few years have been so hard,
but now the paths are revealing themselves again
in really exciting ways.
And so I'm seeing much more radical financial facilities
being built with a clearheaded rationale for what's needed.
So an example in your town, Los Angeles,
is Everytable, the restaurant.
So guy named Sam Polk, he's a Wall Streeter.
Getting burned out on Wall Street
and learns about this phenomenon of food deserts.
You go into an urban center
and same as I was talking about with water and the poor.
Food is exorbitantly expensive.
You can't get nutritious food.
It's just a lot easier and faster
for people actually to get fast food
because nothing else exists.
And so his first move is a classic first move,
I'll start a nonprofit.
And that nonprofit is very effective
in helping people understand,
but it doesn't solve the problem.
So he ultimately decides to create a restaurant
that is fast, nutritious, and affordable, called Everytable.
And he starts in Compton.
That restaurant is so appreciated by the local residents
that he quickly scales to eight restaurants.
We're early investors, so we're all happy.
When the pandemic hits,
and I saw this across our portfolio,
how darkness can reveal the best of us.
Sam decides I'm not letting this slow me down.
On day one of lockdown, he sends a tweet that says,
if you need food, we'll deliver it to you.
If you can't afford it,
our mission is fast, affordable, nutritious food,
we'll deliver it anyway.
And if you're willing to pay it forward, here's a link.
And within weeks, they were delivering tens of thousand,
then hundreds of thousands of meals,
then government partnered with them
so that they could reach homeless shelters
and the people who had no access.
As of today, they've delivered something
on the order of 8 million meals.
It's incredible.
They've significantly grown their company.
And along the way, Sam had always wanted to build franchises
that were run by employees.
And he started to learn
that when you look at the McDonald's franchises,
and other franchises,
the percentage of black and brown owned franchises
is incredibly low.
And so he, again, started to look at
what are the constraints
that keep people from being wealth owners, franchise owners?
And can we focus specifically
on the systemic racist constraints?
And so he built, well, his team built Everytable Academy
where they would allow high performing employees
who wanted to run their own franchise to get trained.
He understood they had no capital to put up front
to build their franchise.
So went out and is raising a $10 million loan facility
where people will get a very, very low interest rate
over the next 10 years.
But that facility will then be onlend
to the franchisee prospects.
He will give them three years
where they will be guaranteed $45,000 income
so that they can still pay for their family to survive.
And over the next seven to 10 years,
when they pay off their loan to Everytable Academy,
they will be full-fledged franchise owners,
employers, wealth holders.
And he's on track.
Everytable is on track
to open 65 franchises by the end of 2022.
So watch this space.
And I'm moving to New York city, my city.
Yeah, they gotta be in New York.
They should be all over New York.
They should be all over this country.
That's an example, right?
Is that, it's saying we can control the market.
We don't have to be controlled by the markets.
Economics is not physics.
Economics is a social construct
that we actually have a say in.
And so yes, use the tools of capitalism
so that we can have this generation and this ideation
and this distribution,
and see where there have been long-term systemic injustices,
fix them, give people a chance,
and watch the magic that happens.
That's what so many of these companies are doing.
That's beautiful, I mean, I know that the gravamen
of your focus is and has been in Africa,
but this being in the United States and addressing,
you know, this is like a problem and an issue
that comes up on the podcast all the time.
The fact that we have these food deserts
and the people who need access to healthy nutrition the most
are deprived of it.
And it's a very simple and elegant solution that leverages
the best of capitalist market forces
and creative kind of business planning
to remove those barriers
and allow these people to become stakeholders
and invested in the success of the affair,
you know, each franchise, of course,
but the whole affair altogether.
It's really powerful, like it's cool.
It's so cool.
And we've got 30-some odd companies
across the United States,
many of which are bringing in ideas
from the rest of the world and using them.
A company called Esusu run by a Nigerian immigrant,
Abbey Wemimo and Samir Goel, his partner.
And Esusu is an African,
in Kenya, we called the merry-go-rounds.
It's 10 women would get together.
We'd each put a dollar in the pot,
at the end of the week, one of us would get the $10
and then the next week we would put our dollar in the pot
and somebody else would get it.
And so depending on where you are in the cycle,
you're a borrower or you're a lender.
And so Esusu is using that same idea,
but to help people build credit records
which are so hard to do in the United States
by virtue of whether and how consistently
they pay their rent.
During the pandemic, very similar and success breed success.
So they went out, Acumen helped them start a grant facility
for rent relief to say, we are in this together.
This is a pandemic.
And if you can't pay your rent, let us know,
we'll get you through it
so that you can keep your credit record.
And when you can pay us back, pay us back.
And I'm seeing these models,
and frankly, these entrepreneurs
becoming the kinds of role models that we need,
because they don't care about again the left right politics,
what they care about is solving problems
in ways that put the poor and the world at the center,
not just profit.
And that's the moral revolution, right?
It is moving away from a frame that sees everything
as the individual and everything as profit,
and those who are successful are only those who are
getting money, power, or fame
to a world that insists on putting our shared humanity
and the sustainability of the earth at the center.
How can you help impress upon people
that interconnectedness?
Like I feel like if there is a,
you know, kind of virus that's infecting us as a culture
outside of, you know, the COVID virus,
it's this idea of individualism and I'm here to get mine.
And it's all about like me accumulating,
you know, irrespective of anyone else's concern.
So disabusing people of that manner of thinking
and getting them into a broader, more compassionate,
inclusive mindset of contributing rather than extracting,
'cause fundamentally, this is all about that.
And you say it outright in the book.
It's like can we live our lives where,
you know, when it's all said and done,
we've contributed more than we've taken.
And if we could create a capitalist metric around that
and sort of judge people's success based upon
how much you're contributing
rather than how much you're extracting,
we would all be in a better place.
I think it's about a change in consciousness.
One that's actually happening,
and you see it in plant-based worlds,
that when you think about how we treat our animals
is how we treat ourselves,
how we treat our bodies is how we treat ourselves,
I think there is a growing consciousness
and we've got to expand that in the stories that we tell
in the way that we model leadership.
I was just with the poet, Marie Howe,
who was the Poet Laureate of New York.
And she talks about,
if only we could remember when we were ocean.
We are all the earth, we're all made of stars.
We are all part of each other and
in your life and in my life story, after story
is nothing but the interdependence.
The story of getting the 45% of the African continent
that doesn't have electricity, electricity.
Maybe used to be their problem.
Now it's all of our problem because Africa, as a continent,
is set to double in population over the next 25 to 30 years,
going from 1.2 to 2.4 billion.
Suddenly anybody who has a 19 or 20 year old
knows what a kid is like,
that's the median age on that continent.
If we in Europe and the United States
weren't worried about refugees and immigration,
it's time now to see that correlation.
That what happens there impacts us.
There was a 15 year old that, Rich, from India.
And she said, "I am an Indian girl.
I am a girl from India and I am a girl from earth."
And I thought, God bless you, God bless your generation.
That it isn't binary.
We can't just be nationalist or globalist.
We have to be both.
And it's not just our connection
and our connectedness to each other.
It's to all living things.
Teilhard de Chardin who's a Jesuit philosopher who I love
and read a lot of said,
"We are not human beings having a spiritual experience.
We are spiritual beings having a human experience."
And so I use the word moral almost as proxy
for that transcendent, for that spiritual, for that belief
that we are on this earth together for a very short moment.
And I believe that we come in almost as circles
and you and I are in a circle of a generation.
It goes in a second.
How do we use that time?
How do we wanna be remembered by those future generations?
I certainly don't want them to look back at us and think,
we didn't care, but that we tried.
And it's only when we see
that we are not just part of each other, we are each other,
that I think we'll really solve these problems.
That's so beautifully put,
and I have a million other things
that I'd like to talk to you about,
but I think you just stuck the landing
and I don't even wanna say anything else.
You could still say.
But I do, I guess before we round this out,
I do wanna leave people with a few thoughts.
You know, I think a lot,
I think most people are struggling with trying to figure out
how to build more purpose into their lives
or find a way to be more fulfilled
or, you know, how can I be more service-oriented
in the free time that I have.
So how do you think about helping to,
you know, catalyze people on this journey of trying to,
you know, figure that out for themselves
and contribute along the way?
Well, I have two answers to that.
And one, I hope doesn't sound self-promotional,
but the first answer is if a young person comes to me,
it's really asking them
what do they love doing?
What are they good at doing?
What does the world need from them?
Again, the Jesuits would say,
go to where your deepest journey meets the world great need.
And too often, we start with the I.
What's my purpose, what's my passion,
rather than if you see a problem that interests you,
go toward it, be curious about it.
I have story after story of people who just start that way
and end up making this their lives work.
If you still have no clue as to what you do next,
find a leader that you admire and get close to that person,
learn from them.
You never know what direction that person will bring you.
But because so many people were coming to us
and coming to me over the years,
we started first a fellows program at Acumen
where we brought people in for a year
and we put them in our companies around the world.
And then we started fellows programs
within country after country.
And now we have about a thousand fellows across the world
who are doing just amazing things
across race, class, ethnicity, religion.
And then we thought we should start sharing this.
And so we built Acumen Academy
as the world school for social change.
So it's an online, this is the self promotional part.
It's an online platform where anyone anywhere
can take a series of courses that start with, who am I?
What can I build?
Because this is a moment that needs all of us.
It needs us to be conscious
about how we spend our money, who do we give it to?
What do we do?
How do we spend our time?
With whom do we walk?
My grandmother always said,
show me who you walk with and I'll show you who you are.
And so the purpose-driven life isn't necessarily
under this rubric of
someone that's deserving of a medal or what have you.
It's a life that's intentional.
It's a life that's conscious of our action and our inaction.
It's a life that's full of curiosity.
It's a life that does a regular accounting
of whether you're giving more than you're taking.
And that asks regularly, not,
am I getting richer, thinner, more beautiful,
but what am I doing to give other people a sense of self,
a sense of their beauty, a sense of their possibility,
a sense of their dignity.
I think that's what it's all about.
Yeah, thank you for that.
I think that's the final word.
You just want me to shut up?
No, I don't, we've been going for two hours.
I could go for another two hours.
I wanna leave people wanting more though.
What a beautiful soul you are, thank you so much.
I really appreciate you sharing today
and I just feel good in your presence.
You know, you have a really great energy about you
and I have so much respect for the work that you do
and appreciate you sharing it today.
The book is "Manifesto For a Moral Revolution."
Have you read "The Book of Hope,"
the book that came out about Jane Goodall?
I have it, I haven't read it yet.
Jane Goodall is who I wanna be when I grow up.
There's a lot of parallels between your book and that book
in the sensibility, like this,
I felt like a sensibility that you share with Jane
in this like "Audacity of Hope" throughout her life
and all of the amazing things that she's done,
like holding onto hope
and having this optimistic but fierce disposition
and commitment to continuing to solve these big problems
and this reverence and excitement that she has
about the younger generations and all of-
There's a lot of shared like thematic sensibility
in your book with her book.
Well, that is the biggest honor you could pay me.
I've had the privilege of meeting her a few times
and talk about being in someone's presence,
she's a extraordinary and she's a lighthouse.
Where I think you also share,
this is a moment where so many people
move from places of disrespect from shaming
and throwing dispersions.
Jane focuses on the possible, on seeing goodness,
on building from that goodness.
And I've never heard her shame
in ways that demean.
She alights, ever, ever, and we need more of that.
And it can be complicated
because sometimes it seems to a younger person,
or maybe just any people,
sometimes it seems that,
well, you're not truth telling,
you're not really standing on what's right,
rather than, oh yes, you are.
And you try to cross her, you won't get very far.
And I feel the same.
But really understanding the psychology of change, right?
Shaming people isn't gonna move the needle.
It might make you momentarily feel
bigger than the other person, but that's a fleeting thing.
I've never seen it push people to act.
No, of course not, right.
So you have to consensus build,
you have to work within systems and outside of systems.
And we need all manner of revolutionaries.
We need the people on the edges as well
holding everyone else accountable.
Like all voices are needed.
But I think you sit in this place
where you have this facility for creating,
like taking the mechanisms of banking
and all these things that most people
don't understand at all and getting them to work
in unison with a purpose and a goal
that I think we can all get behind.
Well, let's be really clear,
I hire people who are a lot smarter than me.
Well, that's smart too, yeah.
But yeah, I do think that that is what it's about.
We've got the tools, we've got the skills.
We certainly have capital as a world.
And that is where that piece of moral imagination,
that consciousness that we are in this together
and that we rise and we fall together
is the piece that we've got to hold together,
whether we're the storytellers and the amplifiers
or the builders, whether we're the entrepreneurs
or the financiers, we're all needed.
Amen, sister.
Amen.
All right, "Manifesto For a Moral Revolution,"
pick it up wherever you buy books.
And Jacqueline, you're easy to find on the internet.
Where's the place you want to direct people?
To acumen?
Yeah, acumen.org,
on the website.
All right, and come back and talk to me again sometime.
I would love it.
Delightful.
I really appreciate it.
Thank you.
Thanks.
Peace.
(upbeat music)